diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit brk
monday cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Applaus]
auf schweizer feldern werden jährlich
mit viel aufwand hunderttausend der ton
und früchte und gemüse angebaut doch
fast die hälfte davon wird weggeworfen
das besagt dass vielleicht ist ja dass
man bekämpfen
das ist das nur mit dem erwähnt
paritätische abfall
foto ist muss nicht sein immer mehr
menschen unternehmen mit was dagegen
weiter geht es mit tomaten und wo man
das noch nicht verbraucht kann ich das
hat dann ja auf großes interesse
gestoßen zentralem platz und damit die
priester wirklich einer trage vor allem
junge wollen nicht mehr akzeptieren das
einwandfreie lebensmittel auf den
feldern liegen bleiben oder wegen
kleiner mängel nicht in die läden kommen
[Musik]
es war ja nicht irgendwo hinter sich 850
millionen lizenzen und mädchen der
botschafter sowieso abschnitt schießen
warum gibt es in der schweiz so viel
foto ist was läuft falsch
was kann man dagegen tun
[Musik]
das erste ist restaurant der schweiz
der ehemalige junior mercury
verwirklicht hier seinen lebenstraum
wenn ich da gut vorbereitet erhält
obwohl mit show und zwar hat die
oberfläche
das shape ups prozent von der komplette
vor eingewandert eines jahres liegt vor
weltweit größte portal oder die glatte
oberfläche und mehr sagen habe ihn
verarbeitete versierteste lucero und
warum haben wir das sehr sehr gut
verarbeiten die knicks die hände von
meinem hof ganz in der nähe vor hier wo
er ist wickie hey was vorstellung melone
vermarkten
und darum brauche es liegt an ihm das
macht uns auch pro wo das berufsbild und
das auto kommen super gründeten eine
blume politik machen
mit einem hebekran und der flieger
silikon soße
in der heimat familie ist mir bewusst
wurde mitten in einer phase
und so hat vorfahrt einer vergangenen
epoche und warum speedway boris frau
seine mutter und auch sein schwager
arbeiten mit
billiger ist das essen hier jedoch nicht
moment wo sie fußball ist sehr 40
investieren
das ist der punkt wie das konventionelle
und der server pro sie beschloss am
entwischen die ganze arbeit und
wirtschaft wo man die steckt ist ein
ersatzprodukt opel macht der buße
schließt davor irgendwo bis über
produkte oder fairer preis und damit
fallen auch unser kam ich sage nicht
dass es hier für günstige risch und
biete hawass einfach günstig ist sondern
wir mehrere flüge
das 100 prozent verarbeitet wird und
dass auf der fall der dominikaner
übernimmt in der region zürich gemüse
das zu klein oder zu groß ist für den
handel
und darum in der biogasanlage landen
würde
[Musik]
verschiedene bruder yannic aber alles
ist 2 quasi zusammen und jetzt für 37
franken pro paket gibt es sechs kilo
gemüse mit zwei bis drei runden 12
nachdem bekannt geworden ist der mini
casa weil er 2018 über facebook in
kürzester zeit 30 tonnen überschüssige
tomaten verkauft hat die tomate zwei
geschafft haben aber noch nicht das ziel
will man jetzt zurück und haben wir das
wissen sondern als hexe hat dann dann
muss er jetzt mache ich habe alles stand
ist es eine frechheit dass neu ist das
leistet will man das land sind was ich
nicht selber ernähren wenn man es mit
importieren
aber damit noch mehr
das romantische und das mit der sie muss
der luxus leistet das mainboard barca
hat sein studium als umweltingenieur
abgebrochen um sich voll auf das shoot
waist engagement zu konzentrieren
auch hier helfen freunde und familie mit
[Musik]
das gewusst sie hatte sich informieren
sich sogar schon die top-ten bremszonen
der flugsicherung schon früher
biologisch sonst hat sich dass möglichst
die konsequenz dass das thema von
tourist ist allgegenwärtig in der
landwirtschaft in der gastroszene aber
am meisten shooter ist mehr als eine
million tonnen fällt in den
privathaushalten an vanessa berger hat
einen zweijährigen sohn
seine geburt hat ihre sicht auf die
dinge verändert so einfach
verantwortlich gefühlt für das nicht
machen so standen hinter dem und wenn
nicht dann mach ich denn unser warum
machen dann das seither versucht sie
nichts mehr wegzuwerfen
vor dem ministerium hofft contamines
spezifisch nachdem monika hofer und
jetzt seien es geht um geld
jetzt habe ich einfach mini me
grundnahrungsmittels getreten sache und
ein kühles und meistens nicht einfach
kombiniert sachen boni und die zum
beispiel selber machen und ich gemacht
habe zum teil auch bester dann ist es
halt gemacht und jetzt machen selber das
lieblingstier gibt es sofort rein wir
eigentlich alle recht einfach
weggeworfen und jetzt praktisch mit fast
einzige weg war für sie wirklich abfall
also für straße und zwischen alles
irgendwie probieren oder irgendwie
zwischen ihren abfall konnte sie so
massiv reduzieren und das ist jetzt
[Musik]
also vorne im foyer viel diskreter sex
pro woche kann das heißt im monat 280
liter und jetzt ein bis zwei liter mirko
buli bespricht mit seinem koch die
nächsten mensch auch er wird nichts weg
gxs noch herrscht ruhe und nix eine
schiene
genau hier fast wie mit
die produktionsplanung sehr wichtig für
die zwei wochen über 6 prozent vor der
abfälle die gastronomie bestehende
produktion und zurück das restaurant
überlässt er heute seiner frau mann für
die ngo united ergänzt waste fährt er
nach grindelwald umfelds zu verhindern
hotel belvedere ohne teamcoaching macht
mit dem land hoch mit ihm zusammen logo
media und versuche die reduzieren 61
prozent mit email mehr ganz so trist aus
der profi ist sehr gefragt das
restaurant läuft gut der berät anderer
gibt kochkurse ist auf dem besten weg
größer zu werden
aber das ist nicht das was er will wenn
das große geld machen wenn eine von
ihnen
das habe das gerne machen aber mir ist
es ja eben glücklich mit landschaft mit
dem schwank mit dem manu in der größe
wie sie 200 dass er machte am tag für
mich stimmt das ist als master zeigt
okay hier ist gut und das ist ja schon
mal wichtige erkenntnis der studie trust
der mann muss wachsen und das teil
dieser gesellschaft und wir glauben das
ist einer von der großen denke er hat
seine prioritäten anders gesetzt
der abfahrts macher offenbar glaubte
system
stress schrittmacher bewusst werden
das ist auch völlig nicht bewusst werde
versteckt verdrängt vergessen
[Musik]
auch im hotel belvedere muss mirko die
zuerst klarmachen dass in der
gastronomie sehr viel protest entsteht
das sind in zahlen vom bundesamt für
umwelt 2,6 millionen tonnen jährlich
werden entsorgt
es gibt verschiedene akteure die da
mitwirken wird auch verantwortlich ist
haben wir die astronomie 11 prozent sehr
hoch das sind 290.000 tonnen
wie viele portionen könnte ich servieren
wenn ich ein halbes kilo drauf machen
würde
290 millionen mal zweiter wie viele
leute könnten dazu nach dessen
vorbeikommen 580 mio
50 zu erklären produktionen teller könnt
ihr euch vorstellen 580 millionen stelle
das ist das sind die einwohner ganz
südamerika story zeigt auf wo der abfall
entsteht
grabstätten größte opfer ist auch konnte
und dass wir noch heute als er gestern
morgen küche überproduktion das größte
problem zweitgrößte immer teller verkauf
würde die bestätigen das ist hier denn
auch der fall
ja das ist nichts vom lager abgelaufenen
habe das ist auch für über aufhören und
sagen
er rechnet auch vor wie viel das hotel
mit einer vollkostenrechnung ganz
konkret sparen könnte 18 kilo mal 24
die wir bewusst haben soll es an hauser
von der besitzerfamilie rechnet und
staudt
dominik wasser beliefert auch
restaurants
[Musik]
also könnte ich das schaffe verbindet
oder landwirtschaft und der konsumenten
konsumentinnen widerrufs bauermann
glaubt dass ist der hauptgrund rainhard
print wie soll man das problem zum food
west hand wir wissen dass das braucht
bis es republik sich laut rechsteiner
und wenn man das nicht wieder die
wertschätzung gewinne dann sind bereits
gegen die verschwendung machen und das
heißt dass man das durch verschiedenste
aktionen projekt wie das café bar in
zürich kocht nachhaltig und regional bei
küchenchef roman wies trend dominik
waser offene türen ein
vom jahrgang der regel an ihren sport
und tanz genießen
komisch fahrzeug passt mir sehr
schmerzhaft wenn überzeugt
beste nation und hochheben und auf meine
kappe
[Musik]
wenn man aus mir wert dass die dinge
sich jeweils wirklich zum charlottes
auch weitermachen und mitmachen wenn es
nicht lief es im schnitt noch draußen
erst und verdammen weil ich das gemäss
steigern
die jugendorganisation der mich zum
beispiel das thema
problematischer ist ein weiterer schritt
war die 77
ist es nicht besser beurteilen kann was
produzieren das gelogen haben oder
staaten die uns helfen jetzt mal
funktioniert und ein doppel sechs ist
die homogenität zu
[Musik]
vanessa berger kauft zwar keine zweit
glas ware aber sie geht regelmäßig auf
den markt und kauft direkt von den
bauern
diese müssen neue absatzmärkte finden
weil sie im großhandel immer weniger für
ihre produkte bekommen
[Musik]
viele finden die lebensmittel auf dem
markt zu teuer
dabei geben die schweizerinnen und
schweizer im schnitt nur noch 6,7
prozent ihres lohnes für lebensmittel
aus
die partner ganz normaler lohn
ich hoffe jetzt nicht so verbreitet
ganze die und stelle online dieses
jahres und dann legen die ablage sie
doch selber fragen kann mit der beta zu
haben aber das haben wir für die ganze
woche
das ist zwar weniger für die ganze bucht
und dann finde ich es ok eigentlich also
dies gelang kräftige news und wird
besteht also es war wirklich schlecht
aber wir fühlen dass sie sagen zum
beispiel ja vielleicht einfach andere
beteiligt
[Musik]
gleich 100
wir holen
[Musik]
in der landwirtschaft werden jedes jahr
200.000 tonnen lebensmittel produziert
und weggeworfen bevor sie überhaupt in
den verkauf kommen
mirko burri sammelt solche lebensmittel
ein aber das offene ohr und die abnahme
wird legehenne klicke hier los wo
überhaupt schnitte wie schnittlauch wo
es überhaupt fahren und die hinterzimmer
sortiert und die fahrerwertung zischte
und wollen herr audi überschuss von
verschiedenen diese schlichte breit
abgestützt sie untergeschoss hat das mit
wieder andere prominente unterstützen
über rust bz
fast alle bauern produzieren überschüsse
aber viele haben angst auf die
missstände aufmerksam zu machen
pascal gutknecht betreibt im freiburger
seeland einen großen betrieb mirco burri
ist nicht der einzige der überschuss
ware bezieht
auch simon weidmann der die essbar und
den gemüsegarten in der berner altstadt
betreibt holt hier regelmäßig seine ware
ja das war ganz großes liefers
abgeschnitten unförmig das sind die
normalen handel verkaufen
bisherige systeme sich der suboptimalen
selber di grassi gibt gegen das grosse
ein grundsätzliches rebellisches
republik frankreich anfang egal ob so
und darüber so groß das macht keinen
unterschied ist genau gleich sein wenn
wir einen schnitt und ihn so lautet eine
verkaufte er hat den wert einer führung
hatten gern tat sehr viel energie
antrieb schreckt worden
und darum muss unters volk beim oscar
weiter und mir bewiesen dass es
funktioniert mehr kunden von denen jeder
tag und es kaufen sich zeigen mit geld
die berufs für y net praktischen
kaum zu glauben was sie alles als zweit
glas wahre lügen bleibt und vor allem
auch aus welchen gründen schließlich
irgendwie vielleicht im wachstum
angeschlagen ist kaliber wachstums ist
es einfach egal wie viel weniger
züchtete sorte du fertig bist du periode
nicht für möglich hält dass sie schön
homogen rot wird das sich aus war
grundsätzlich gilt ja das ist schon hier
vom trio tomate wurde so etwas braucht
energie 15 mm und ist sprachlich so gut
dass mit der kv schweiz
das ist ein und da nun aber haben sie
sie einfach medium ist sitzt um zu mir
und zeigten mir als eine bessere zu
versuchen
kleins hast du warst das land für das
produkt risch und schloss an tischen das
war klar
mit pcs oder landtag fordern und das
problem mit fußball ist weil sie die
supermarkt in einem schönen stöße
zwischen kritik und verwöhnte
high-end-segment exportieren
trotz nach modischen man kennt dann auch
normal lang mit blättern ist eigentlich
der laut taylor der blätterteig grünen
art speziell für vitamine hat schnitt
man heute nicht so gut das passt oder
beim einkaufen da in kürze auch das geht
der ausbau von 21 prozent von
gesamtgewicht wo ja gewachsen ist was
falsch war und das geht mit ausnahme des
build offen hält
besuchen perfekt sei es im
schlussendlich
[Musik]
deswegen ein bisschen sie ständig gut
ist dass man sagt das heißt das dass man
bekämpfen
das ist das nicht mehr mit dem erwähnten
kassel tätig das heißt sie frei damit
sie irgendwann wieder sich 850 millionen
tassen und stefan ries gehört zur fenaco
gruppe
diese macht die strengen vorgaben im
konventionellen gemüseanbau zusammen mit
den branchenverbänden der produzenten
und den detaillisten wie migros und coop
die fenaco gruppe ist die marktmächtigen
drehscheibe im großhandel
sie macht einerseits die am bau planung
für die bauern nimmt deren
landwirtschaftsprodukte ab sortiert
diese aus und verkauft die ware an die
detaillisten
ein problem muss eine gewisse länge
dicke und größe haben damit es überhaupt
weiter verarbeitet wird von der fenaco
möchte niemand auskunft geben man
verweist an den verband der
gemüseproduzenten bfmt tv quiz das
niveau ist zur zeit von 8 bis 9 uhr
stimmt und wir sind immer bereit
qualitätsnormen zu dürfen das vor vier
jahren das letzte mal passiert
und wenn die dann entsprechend vor die
versuche zur seite stand
in der lebensmittelverarbeitenden
industrie gingen letztes jahr rund
700.000 tonnen lebensmittel verloren
das hat das bundesamt für umwelt
berechnet
[Musik]
für blei wie diese landen in der
biogasanlage
[Musik]
beim schweizer bauernverband ist man mit
den strikten vorgaben was das aussehen
der landwirtschaftsprodukte betrifft
nicht einverstanden
diese botschaft ist ganz klar würde mir
die toleranz was die qualitätskriterien
anbelangt großzügiger werden
es macht wirklich sinn wenn man daher
nach guten produkt einmal durchs raster
schlussendlich nach einer panne trat der
nahrungsmittelkette verwahrte
entsprechend müssen die einzelnen
branchen die qualitätskriterien möglich
kritisch hinterfragen vorne wo das nötig
ist viele bauern haben allerdings angst
vor solchen anpassungen
denn der handel droht mit
unberechenbaren konsequenzen
es wird seit jahren die
qualitätskriterien gelockert werden
der auch für erstens konsumentinnen
konsumenten weniger von dem produkt also
der markt zurück und auf der anderen
seite wird er unser gesetz habe nach
einer die qualität von denen schweizer
produkt eigentliche krankheit und
importprodukten nach einer die höheren
qualitätsstandard der schweizer
konsumentinnen und konsumenten auf die
importprodukte und thom yorkes richtige
glaube aber es muss die ganze welt
zusammen ausmachen
es gibt aber auch betriebe die sich dem
diktat der großhändler endziel der
gutsbetrieb rheinau gehört dazu hier
wird nachhaltig produziert und noch von
hand gerettet
david jacobson ist einer der
geschäftsführer
nur einmal hat er bisher versucht mit
den großen händlern ins geschäft zu
kommen
wir haben zweimal mit der umstellung auf
dem weg von der autobahn ihm
ausgerüstete mit betriebe die schweiz
und hat kunden
doch vielleicht können wir das positiv
beeinflusse und im rückblick sie aber
mit gemachten aufnahmen schalotten ab
mein körper baut wir haben geld gebaut
und eigentlich sie mir kriegen sie von
mir und kreativ und dann sind die preise
im keller und wir haben der forschung
sowie priester sind und der hbh nicht in
den mitbruder zu seinem preis
lieferungen könnten mehr wie der
anbieter wenn ihren nachteilige preis
zahlen und ich habe noch nie eine
freundin für der handel mit bioprodukten
funktioniert gleich aber über andere
plattformen david jacobson ist überzeugt
dass dieses system die unbefriedigende
situation mit ausgelöst hat und den
bauern schadet das heißt die plattform
hat zwar einzelne produkt zu liefern und
das allein acht menschen und tieren die
produkte aber auch eine lieferung wenn
sie es nicht können wir wenn man sie
bezahlen und zum die börse umgang machen
sie ihr plan was auch viel zu viel
arbeit plant fürs normale 15 jahren mal
von zwillingen tvo und das ziel muss
irgendwo abgebaut werden und dass wir
dann halt abgestufte pur und
wirkungslose bürgersaal gebucht haben
kann raten die tabs in die gleiche
leistung und gleichzeitig für den rest
eine unschlagbare preise über dem markt
gesättigt ist und deutsches problem
die rheinau macht bei dieser
überproduktion nicht mit und hat sich
auf den direktverkauf an marktfahrer
läden und restaurants konzentriert zudem
nimmt man hier in kauf dass nicht alles
jederzeit verfügbar ist
[Musik]
betriebe wie die reine aus die ausnahme
die meisten bauern arbeiten wie pascal
gutknecht mit den plattformen der
großhändler zusammen sie machen auch die
anbauplanung mit ihnen zählte ideen
das hätte jetzt schon bereits platzten
die müssen wir die tiere genau und das
ist das wird aus dem schuss sinne also
also ich auch nicht ganz so einfach
jahres plan mit dem vortag lagen konnte
und natur endlich die baudaten den also
plötzlich auf selbiges habe zwei wochen
nachdem sie erst sagte buchheim diese
high und schlagwerk der salat drei
wochen später sie also dass der punkt
landes mache ich sehr schwierig die
union immer möglich während autofahrer
war schon sagt er durch schützt du hast
du schon sagen das ist so schwierig das
zu planen
der bruch zu große toleranz von
produzent zum zum hunderte von spielen
doch immer häufiger bringen bauern ihre
ware gar nicht mehr los eine
abnahmegarantie haben sie nämlich nicht
das signal ab wache gehalten
ob sich der woche für woche später das
nicht zu entscheiden aber zu 1400 holt
seit jahren im hause spanier billiger
gekommen
er hatte hier bin
[Musik]
ja er ist resultat zählt ist einfach
produziert wieder vollgeschosse und am
besten durch langfristige bisher nichts
bewirken dass der produzent neuen ihk
oder die detaillisten übernehmen diese
waren nicht sie können auswählen und
nehmen nur das beste alles schön
normiert lehnt ein interview ab
bei migros weiß man um den zwiespalt und
gibt auskunft
das auge ist nicht nur mit sondern das
auge kauft also mehr gesehen das mich
gespürt dass man die erfahrung gemacht
dass unsere kundinnen kunden doch so
sehr die flüge dass das produkt werden
schön aussehen und wenn man so virtuelle
probieren dass man das wieder ins
bewusstsein bringt für die
sensibilisierung wieder erregt wir
unseren kundinnen kunde ist klar alle
anlieger strang ziehen ist das ziel
definiert wurden alle zusammen der
branche pro verschaffen
alle zusammen
das sind die verbände die grossisten und
die detaillisten
[Musik]
wer ihre mikro den bereit die strengen
optischen bestimmungen zu lockern
es ist ein drittes thema effektiv dass
man das wieder mal oft trifft hier sind
die norma im moment sind jetzt tragen wo
sie die lockere das meisterteam league
in kleinen schritten stattfinden
aber ich das gefühl dass eine grund
bewusst sie ist mittlerweile wieder
kunden ein kunde auto dafür was passiert
wenn ein produkt nach dem sie leben
können gekauft werden und ich glaube
wenn auf der sie werden vielleicht
entgegen hoch und wenn die medizin
gemeinsam etwas machen der highschool
kommt das schon gerichten und weist im
laden zu verhindern
steigt micro nun landesweit bei der
futurist up to get to go ein was nicht
mehr so gut aussieht im gestell wird
jeden tag aussortiert und kurz vor
ladenschluss als überraschungspaket zu
einem drittel des preises abgegeben
doch schon einiges zusammen gekommen ja
genau das ist das problem von therapien
ziemlich
wenn wir das nicht abrufen wenn man das
an stadtwerken können wir das migros
gibt schon bisher einen teil der
ausschuss ware an organisationen wie
tischlein deck dich oder schweizer tafel
ab das ist ein unterschied zwischen der
produkte jetzt für die gute sache ob
produkt thomas der karitative
organisationen werbe tischlein deck dich
schweizer darauf dass ich bin vor allem
auch richtig konserve also produkt wohl
noch länger heben bitte gute ganz
wichtig um die sache wohl unmittelbar
dass er den ablauf etwas mit der
ausstellung von dienst bringt mit der
art kann man die portionen reservieren
und kurz vor ladenschluss abholen
die kunden die kommen kommen regelmäßig
also manchmal zweimal pro woche also
einmal probiere ich mit natürlich hast
viele tage vor ein billiger kreis
mittlerweile machen 2.000 restaurants
und läden mit mikro alleine kann so pro
jahr eine million portionen gemüse und
früchte billiger weitergeben die sonst
im abfall landen würden
[Musik]
auch die nachfrage nach leeden die
ausschließlich 2 klass ware verkaufen
steigt die essbar und der gemüsegarten
in der berner altstadt beweisen dass
simon weidmann hat vor zwei jahren
angefangen das gemüse dass er bei pascal
roth nicht geholt hat verkauft sich gut
[Musik]
wir sind dezent an das ist afrika in
stücke für den pc und das klavier und
wieder aber es ist ein hartes pflaster
die margen sind klein aber das land wird
nicht in der hand wir glauben der
beschluss möglich zu machen wir nichts
bewegen und gesünder als landsmann
chaker wachsen und so mehrere der
mitgründer der s bahn gleich nebenan ist
optimistisch bei der s-bahn war es
ähnlich
hier bekommt man seit vier jahren
backwaren einen tag später zum halben
preis
und jetzt ich habe größte stück toleranz
das basiskonzept und zuteil denn der
wechselkurs elite und zwar mit mokka die
hand
[Musik]
der gelernter geograf ist überzeugt dass
es beim gemüsegarten ähnlich laufen wird
mittlere friss oder stirb mentalität wo
im handel herrscht und saß im editor ist
für dasselbe von marco bruni hat 1500
kilo 2 das gemüse für seine
straßenaktion food factory
zusammengekauft eine neue idee ein start
up das er vor drei jahren gegründet hat
dafür trommelt er regelmäßig auf dorf
märkten freiwillige zusammen die ihm
beim rüsten helfen
in worb hat er sein zelt gleich neben
einem altersheim aufgeschlagen
hergestellt wird eine bouillon paste aus
foto ist die sich in läden verkaufen
lässt
und da merkst du dass wird gefährliches
auch wird am nachmittag die ca h da wird
das gefäß machte stimmung für ihre
arbeit gar kein problem investieren wo
ist der it-infrastruktur konzept uns
produkt und deswegen bietet ist ein
zubringer auf um jung namen sagt ein
thema an und hoffe dass frau schwarz
gold und das seit gestern 20
und genau da ist endlich wirklich genau
dass wir früh sowohl aus gewinnspannen
letzter zu nico herzig kongress findet
im wir in baden bahnhofplatz stoff die
komplett erfasst davon genannten affäre
politisch server für die landesmeister
mit und will hier um das eigene telefon
ihr gratis verteilte problem damit
bekannt vom politik gebrochen
[Musik]
mittlerweile hat burri eine große
facebook community
[Musik]
seine familie trägt auch diese aktionen
voll mit ohne manno seine frau die alles
ein bisschen austariert wäre burri
allerdings ziemlich aufgeschmissen
[Musik]
vanessa bergen wird von ihrer familie
ebenfalls unterstützt zusammen mit ihrer
mutter entwickelt die ausgebildete natur
heilpraktikerin gerade eine neue
körperpflege linie ohne verpackung und
ausschließlich mit natürlichen zutaten
bei ihrem mann armin braucht es ein
bisschen mehr überzeugungskraft
[Musik]
er konnte vanessa zero waste bemühungen
am anfang nicht so viel abgewinnen
weiteres praktisches italien spielt eine
sehr große rolle und müssen nicht
unbedingt bekannt wie das mit der sehr
sie beweist sind kochen mit wenig fett
im regine was in der tat mir gut
oder wenn zero waste stattfindet ich
finde es darf ruhig auch etwas anderes
stört die nach wie vor der aspekt wo ist
das sind die kosten ihres kindes mehrere
84 ganzes geld und für der kanzler aber
jetzt kritischer fakt es ist schade dass
es solch es ist schade dass mir der caj
mit walheim quasi zum ziemlich gesund
und günstig
[Musik]
vanessa berger muss noch in den bioladen
ihr ziel ist armin endlich von joghurt
im glas zu überzeugen
[Musik]
talk ist auf die kurse
essen
dr
[Applaus]
mai live
[Musik]
dominik wasser hat in zürich eine neue
futurist aktion gestartet
[Musik]
gerade verkauft er 1,7 tonnen ananas aus
afrika auf facebook konnte man sich
anmelden verkaufsaktionen gibt es in
zürich basel und bern ananas in togo
wurde reduziert und ihr werdet
eigentlichen in handel kommen groß haben
und der dom erkennt man dass sie
zusammen oder ist sammelt dass diese
sind samt und somit größere abnehmer von
gebauter absprünge
darum haben wir jetzt aber doch
importiert wenn für die fleetboard
existenzgründer bieten und bruder bei
nec wird sein okay wenn man die zähne
trockenheit und darum dass man jetzt die
und versuche zu wechseln
[Musik]
eine hauptzone schafft zum von den 35
franken die er für ein kilo ananas
verlangt die in 12 franken direkt an die
bauern auch sein zweiter klasse gemüse
findet guten absatz
dominik wasser versucht nun eine
bewilligung zu kriegen um es hier direkt
verkaufen zu können
ziel ist es mit die aktion jede woche
mache aber das könnte die zeit gibt es
irgendwas produkt oder ganz viele
produktionen zu hause aktion verkaufen
aber es ziehe ich das mal das mache zum
sensibilisieren zum aufmerksamen und
dass man dann wird der handel der
produktion mit so verändere das ist halt
dass das nicht passiert
sein gemüse bezieht wasser unter anderem
auch auf dem demeter hof rainer bei
david jacobson
dieser findet es zwar gut dass dominique
dafür kämpft dass die konsumenten wieder
direkt vom hof kaufen aber dass er mit
seinen fast aktionen 2 klass gemüse der
plattformen verkauft damit ist er nicht
einverstanden mit einer ihre fehlplanung
und verglich sie die produzenten wo oder
andere produzenten oder mietwagen das
versuchsmodell sektor weniger verkaufen
mit spitzer und schweizer handels die
aktion so viel knies und plötzlich mit
credit risk tonnen tomaten direkt am
anderen ort war sie ja quasi das man
weiß dass das geht die problematik des
guten
ja ich glaube die die überschüssige der
fund weise das hat wohl gesagt und
womöglich anbringen und das riese ja in
diese figur macht aber das problem ist
halt viel viel größer und für tiefer und
tiefer trauer
dass zum einen das ist ein systemisches
problem ist und zum anderen dass man
immer eigentlich hochschuldiplom an das
service und sehr oft nicht am tisch
sitzt und rektor gesessen
[Musik]
dass sich die leute zusammen an einen
tisch setzen und sensibilisiert werden
das ist auch das ziel des foto ace
banketts auf dem berner bahnhofplatz
aber so schick habe genau den chef mit
dem lohn von porsche-chef michael macht
in der küche des hotels schweizerhof ein
gratis menü für 1500 personen
als hauptspeise gibt es gemüse bolognese
mit ofenkartoffeln wenig später ist ja
die hauptstimme 209 zwischen hauptsache
und nun sieht van stück blutungen und
ordnung ist
also wenn ich spaß daran ihn als 500 mir
nichts fehlen
und warum die politik ausgerufen
[Musik]
wenn es die politik hier kommen wie für
das erstellen einer schlange 50 euro
das statement estate wir machen mit und
das geht durch kraft eines widgets
machen wo wir machen da keinen aber
mercury ist noch lange nicht am ziel
seiner träume
es ist bahn ist mit das ist riesig es
ist von der schönste größter fußball ist
event wo es geht aber es macht wirklich
größe bis wir können dann bequem 852
erste mal hier im schweizer hof bevor
und da ist mir jetzt das und das und das
kann die macht immer auf das nur max
bürger jetzt schon ganz am anfang aber
nicht wirklich verändert nichts zu sehen
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von dr genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1902